nigeria has the highest rate of
identical twins
china has the lowest rate at only one in
300 births being twins
polar bears most commonly give birth to
twins
22 percent of twins are left-handed
compared to only 10
of non-twins researchers suspect one in
eight people start life as a twin
but because of miscarriages of one of
the fetuses only 1 in 70 people
are actually born twins that's all very
interesting but
what actually causes twins there are two
types of multiple pregnancy
identical and fraternal identical or
monozygotic twins occur when one egg is
fertilized by one sperm
and the fertilized egg splits into two
or more embryos
scientists believe identical twins
happen purely by chance
and there are no contributing factors
such as age
race or family genes one quarter of all
twins
are mirror twins caused by a late split
of the fertilized egg this is when the
twins are direct reflections of each
other one will
always be left-handed and the other will
always be right-handed
if one has a birthmark on the left side
of their face then the other will have
the same birthmark on the right side of
their face
and so on but the reflection is much
more than skin deep
one of the twins will have their
internal organs on the wrong side of
their body
so the heart will beat on the right side
on the other hand fraternal or dizygotic
twins
runs in the family fraternal pregnancy
happens when two or more eggs are
fertilized by different sperm
women can inherit a certain gene which
causes them to
hyper ovulate meaning she is more likely
to release multiple eggs during
ovulation
therefore increasing the chance of
multiple pregnancy
so if anyone in your family has twins or
you yourself are a twin you're much more
likely to have twins yourself
the rate of twins is increasing
dramatically the birth rate of twins has
increased by
76 since 1980. in 1980
one in every 53 babies was a twin
however
today one in every 30 babies born
is a twin which when you think about it
is an awful lot of twins
but what caused such an upsurge one of
the biggest factors
is that the average age of women having
children has risen
and the older the mother is the more
likely she is to give birth to twins
another contributing factor is a rapid
increase in the use of fertility
treatments
that promote the release of multiple
eggs during ovulation but
enough of that let's get on to the
really bizarre stuff
there's a twin town a small town in
brazil cadido gadoi
is the twin capital of the world amongst
the 80 families that live in the town
there are 38 pairs of twins some believe
there's something in the water
that's causing such an astronomically
high number of twin births
what others think there's something much
more sinister going on
researchers have suggested it may have
been caused by a nazi physician
called joseph mengele who had the
nickname angel of death
it has been said that during the 1960s
when the explosion of twins in the town
first occurred mengele was performing
experiments on the women of the town
involving strange new drugs and even
artificial insemination
identical twins aren't identical all
identical twins have distinguishable
qualities from birth
after all identical twins do have
different dna
their dna is extremely similar but not
identical
identical twins also have completely
different
sets of fingerprints twins have their
own language
idioglossia is a language shared between
twins
that only they understand about 40
of twins invents their own language it
sounds complete gibberish to me and you
but it's a close bond shared between the
siblings
this phenomenon can also occur between
very close siblings
but more commonly twins their shared
language
usually disappears by the time they
start school
how different can twins be very twins
can be different genders but
even more astonishing twins can be
different ages
recently there was a case where
five-year-old ruben blake got a brand
new twin sister
even though they had five years between
them they are still
technically twins their mother had
difficulty getting pregnant naturally
so she turns to in vitro fertilization
this is when the eggs are fertilized
outside of the body
then reimplanted into the woman's uterus
but reuben's mother
only had two of the embryos from the
process implanted into her uterus
the other three were frozen a few years
later she had the remaining embryos
implanted and nine months later she gave
birth to ruben's twin sister
believe it or not twins can have
different dads
and be different races it's rare but
about two percent of fraternal twins
have different doubts this happens when
a woman releases two eggs during
ovulation
and then gets impregnated by two
different men at the same time
twins bond in the belly we've all
witnessed the unbreakable bonds that
twins often have
but where does it come from twins
actually bond
physically in the womb researchers at
the university of pedova in italy
noticed by a 3d ultrasound that at 14
weeks old
fetuses reach out for each other in the
womb
at 18 weeks old they were stroking each
other and maintained physical contact
30 percent of the time strangely in
these tests the fetuses avoided touching
each of his eyes
as if they know it's a delicate area so
now you know all about twins but the
story i'm about to share with you will
blow your mind
introducing the twin gyms the prize for
the most incredible twin story
has to go to jim lewis and jim springer
they were born in 1940
and adopted by separate families in ohio
they grew up 45 miles apart from each
other and had no contact for 39 years
when they were reunited in 1979 they
discovered that they were both named
james by their adoptive parents
they both married twice first to women
named linda
and secondly to women named betty they
both had children
jim springer had a boy whom he named
james allen
and jim lewis named his son james allen
with
one elf they both had dogs named toy
they both drank the same beer
smoked the same cigarettes and drove the
same model of car
chevrolets their medical histories were
identical
and they shared the same hobbies
including a woodworking workshop
in both their garages they both had
vacations on the exact same beach
in florida simply incredible
thanks for watching until next time
you